i'm gonna blow your mind you want me to
blow your mind
jfk is not dead
about jack ruby when are we gonna talk
about that shut up and listen to me
jfk is not dead he's living in a
military installation under this
axe and you're gonna be surprised he's
gonna come out on election day
with his son jfk jr also not dead and
they're gonna bring ruth bader ginsburg
out
not dead and execute her for crimes
against humanity
wake up dude i'm a [ __ ] conspiracy
theorist but you you're out of your
[ __ ] mind this [ __ ] sucks man
yeah you paid for this and you're
getting a better tour than you would
ever get by some of these [ __ ] hacks
who keep talking about steve harvey
oswald or any of this [ __ ]
okay i'm telling you what's really going
on the real [ __ ] deal there's a storm
coming are you ready for it
you know jfk is married to right now no
princess diana i
am the guy to give this tour why i
worked at the 911 gift shop
when twa flight 800 went down i jumped
into the ocean to recover parts of the
plane
okay have you ordered the hell bob comet
do you know anything about the rustic
crucians
the sumerians the knights temple these
are soldiers in the war of life you
belong in a [ __ ] home do you think
there was a second shooter you're still
talking about a president who was not
killed and
is not dead i'm trying to wake you up to
the real [ __ ]
satan ruth bader ginsburg chrissy teigen
david spade get it
i'm hungry as [ __ ] he's not buried he's
living in a military installation and
he's gonna come above ground on election
day
and arrest tom hanks and chrissy teigen
what is so hard to [ __ ]
understand jfk is
alive
what what the [ __ ] is going on
[Music]
i think he might be right should we
call someone